let's talk about this story of uh
nuclear bombs and this is from CBS by
the way it's not like it's a blog or
somebody that just wrote it for the heck
of it CBS writes this article okay and
the title reads nuclear war between us
and Russia would kill more than 5
billion people just from starvation's
fine uh study fines even a relatively
small nuclear conflict such as one
between India and Pakistan would be
devastating a week-long nuclear war
involving 100 weapons and the release of
5G 5tg about 11 billion pounds of suit
would kill 27 million people directly
the study said after two years the
international trade at a halt of 34.7
degrees Fahrenheit temperature dropped
the famine it creates would kill 255
million people assuming that the rest of
the population got the minimum food need
to needed to survive about 1999 calories
per capita per day the largest scenario
examine a week-long war involving 4 400
weapons 150 TG 300 30.6 billion pounds
of suit
such as one that would occur between the
U.S its allies and Russia would kill 360
million people directly and more than 5
billion people from starvation when you
hear a story like this we had Peter uh
Dr Peter dry here Peter Peter pry here
twice in one month first time we ever
did that with a guest he came in here we
talked about he was one of the leading
uh voices in the world leading expert
voices in the world in weapons of mass
destruction nuclear bombs he just died a
month ago by the way you know it rest in
peace he died a month ago we had him
four or five months ago
you know
uh Putin making the prediction on a
nuclear weapon that if you do this you
know we're gonna do this and then U.S
warns Putin of catastrophic consequences
of nuclear weapons are used in UK or
Ukraine this is a Reuters Story the US
would respond decisively 20 rushing use
of nuclear weapons against Ukraine and I
spelled out to Moscow the catastrophic
consequences it would face U.S national
security adviser Jake Sullivan on said
on Sunday
etc etc okay
what is the likelihood for any one of
you you know percentage-wise what is the
likelihood that Putin uses a nuclear
weapon against Ukraine at this point
what do you think
what do you think it is
let's just hope that it's freaking very
low Tyler where are you at what do you
think it is with Putin using nuclear
weapons against Ukraine we keep sending
Ukraine 50 60 70 billion dollars I think
the percentage gets higher and higher
and higher every day again we're talking
about Iran right and the protests in
Iran and the people standing up for
freedom and actually something that
could be pivotal in not only the Middle
East but the world right if they were to
overthrow the government this could
fundamentally reshape the Middle East in
the world yet we have no concern about
it right we want to send off 50 60 70
billion dollars and sit there and kick
Vladimir Putin until he turns around and
he punches us what do you think is going
to happen like this is our fault
I think we need to get out of Ukraine
the idea that Ukraine was going to then
move or excuse me that Russia was then
going to move into Poland and totally
reform the USSR is absurd he knows he
doesn't have the power to do that he
knows exactly what would happen if he
did try to do that he wanted to take
over Ukraine because we kept pushing to
put NATO uh in Ukraine have Ukraine
become a part of NATO and put the U.S
military nuclear weapons at his doorstep
and he knows better than that
um I think the chances of him using
nukes get higher and higher and higher
every day is it a one percent is it at
five percent is it a ten percent what do
you think I don't think it's a
full-scale nuclear weapon I think it's a
tactile but I think it's at 15 but I
don't know there's part of what I what
you're saying that I agree with like
we're pushing uh Putin to the edge and
I've been saying this for months now
we've got to get this guy an off ramp if
there's anything that he demands it's
respect if you're feeling disrespected
and you're backed against the wall you
know you're gonna lash out like a you
know scared animal uh but I don't agree
with you Tyler on what is he gonna
invade Poland it's like there's there's
a reason that freaking Finland who has
been basically you know abstaining from
being a part of NATO for 50 years is
like yeah we're gonna join now because
they share a 400 mile border with Russia
so if they can just walk into Ukraine
next thing you know they're walking into
Finland next thing you know walking to
Poland these are legitimate concerns
from bordering countries so I do trust
that our government knows what they're
doing in relation to Ukraine and Russia
that's fine you can be on the other side
of the table that's good but I think
Anthony blinken who's basically running
the show over there is a very competent
individual he just yeah he's the joke I
mean that's great this is why we're in
[ __ ] America that you can have your
opinion you can have that proud boy
opinion I can have my soy boy opinion we
can meet in the middle it's all good but
I do think that the world is basically
spoken that a Madman just can't just
walk into other people's countries and
redefine borders when they just
magically become a Madman why was he not
a Madman in 20 seconds
let's just say a power hungry guy let's
just say it like that I know I know that
your side wants to you know Advocate
Putin that's your guy you kind of have a
poster up on his wall I get with the
at-home however why do you think he
didn't do this in 2016. what was the
first thing that Donald Trump wanted to
do he wanted to abolish NATO what was
the point of NATO was to keep the USSR
in check where's the USSR they haven't
existed since Ronald Reagan the first
thing Trump wanted to do was abolish
NATO and that's what kept Vladimir Putin
at Bay yeah because if somebody's gonna
abolish NATO you're just gonna let them
do what they want to do What's the
phrase if your enemy is basically
shooting himself in the foot go ahead
and shoot your let him shoot themselves
in the foot of course if the president
United States is talking about
abandoning NATO if you're Putin you're
like have at it why do I need to do
anything to to make this happen you're
going to talk about it doing anyway and
there's a high likelihood that if Trump
was re-elected he'd be pushing more and
more and more to get out of NATO right
so I don't I don't agree with this
presumption that if Trump was there then
who knows what happened with Putin
Putin's been basically been calculated
this entire time if there's anything you
want to say about Putin is is calculated
so maybe I misspoke about the madman
thing but the guy could turn into a
[ __ ] madman and basically we don't
give him an offer him so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]